the Toronto Star sports columnist Bruce
Arthur here on the Rich Eisen show how
you doin Bruce Rich I could sleep for a
hundred years but it's the best how are
you uh you know I look I I read your
stuff on on Twitter as you know we've
we've gotten to know this first time
we've ever spoken for we've gotten to
know each other a bit through following
each other on Twitter and I wanted to
have you on the show cuz what would
you've been writing of late what you've
been communicating of late really gets
to the heart of what people are feeling
up there so I'll just throw it up out to
you and say what what what is the
feeling there in Toronto going into
tonight's game I would say it's
something new and it's something new for
a lot of reasons and one of them is if
you're a Raptors fan you started out as
a very small piece of a much bigger
sports puzzle this is a hockey country
right and not only that this is a hockey
town the Toronto Maple Leafs were passed
down from your grandfather to your
father to you and in this town if you're
not a Leafs fan you're something else
and for a lot of people because the
sports room had the head the rafters
became too something else
especially for people of color it's a
very multicultural fan base in a very
multicultural City in a way that other
teams in the city can't quite match and
so if you're a rapper saying you you
started out as kind of another and you
put your heart at the team and then your
stars left
Vince Carter left Chris Bosh left Tracy
McGrady left there kept going and going
and then once your team got good once
they got into the demar derozan Kyle
Lowry Dwane Casey era of the Toronto
Raptors and their Messiah jury the
seasons would end with something
different which was humiliation like I
said LeBron James pulled their pants
down on national TV over and over and
over again and this is finally a team
where Raptors fans don't feel scared
maybe they showed us its Golden State
and all of that like these guys are the
champs but this Raptors team feels
different and so for if your Raptor
sentence is the first time probably in
the franchise history where you've
really been rewarded and so when they
won Game six against Milwaukee to town
just every Raptors fan and all the kind
of casual bandwagon fans command it
exploded you had people on their
balconies
we're shooting cell phone videos and you
could hear it you can
here it in the city and so it's really
is something new there's an excitement
about basketball in the city in this
country that there's never really been
before and the team is finally worthy of
all the love that's important to it from
all these people over all these years
well obviously so many casual fans would
relate this team to Drake right that
he's the most well known fan and also
well-known aspect of the fandom what
what is emblematic of of the fan of the
wraptor fan or this team Bruce is is it
Drake I mean is that a viable is that a
viable picture well that's the one that
people know right and in a way the story
of the rafters can be told they have
another super fan of names mouths bodies
a car dealer he's a first generation
Indian immigrants the two most prominent
fans the team or visible minorities this
Toronto is by pretty much every measure
the most ethnically diverse city in the
world right like we have people from all
over the globe
it's an incredibly multicultural city
and that doesn't make us perfect or
anything but when you look at to me if
you look at the crowds outside the
building and this is something that
happens in other places now but it
happened in Toronto as much as anywhere
first if you look at the fans who were
out there in the cold and the wet and
tonight actually it'll be pretty nice
that crowd looks like the city that
looks like riding the subway in this
town and that to me is what it is is
that this is like for the Torme police
can be a team for everyone because they
are so big they're just so massive
there's the fan base they have is as big
as probably almost any team in North
America but for the Raptors there was
kind of you didn't need the bar of
accessibility in terms of the money it
cost to play hockey right our in terms
of having to learn a sport like
basketball is it globally more popular
sports in hockey this is a sport in this
town for for more people from more
places and not to me is what the fans of
Toronto really is and so Drake kind of
does I mean he's a kid who grew up in a
nice part of town
was an actor he's
is now and good for him and now body Oh
was a first-generation immigrant who got
treated like dirt and then built his way
in this country and those are both kind
of stories of how the Raptors fan base
was built and who they are it's a really
inclusive place and that's something I
really liked Bruce Arthur of the Toronto
Star here on the Rich Eisen show and
then he wrote a piece recently about
this team being put together and and who
they are and it is it is remarkable how
this is an NBA Finals team we know about
Kawhi but how did this team get put
together and get to Game one tonight is
a remarkable story in itself Bruce won
and it's true they did it they don't
have anyone drafted about 15 but they
needed guys drafted about 15 to get here
Marta Rosen was 9 to pick Jakub Pirtle
was a nice pick those guys went in a
trade along with the owners Valanciunas
one went for the Marc Gasol trade and
one went for the Kawhi Leonard trade and
as a result you look at this team and
Kawhi was a 15th pick Kyle Lowry was a
24th pick he's on his third team Serge
Ibaka was a 24th pick he's on his third
team Norman Powell was a second-round
pick Fred vanvleet was undrafted Danny
Green was a second-round pick Marc Gasol
came out of nowhere right he was just
pal Gasol chubby brother but he made
himself into something L did and that's
something that I think just relates to
anybody like for I think I'm like a lot
of people when I don't have a rooting
interest in sport night turn on
television I cheer for the underdog and
that's what this whole team is right
like Nick nurse was a coach who started
out on the other side of the world like
he was coaching in Britain and went
through the G League and wound up here
Masai Ujiri is from Nigeria he's the
only general manager or team president
NBA history from the continent of Africa
these people came from a from a long
ways they had come a long ways to get
here and you can say the same thing to a
lesser degree of the Warriors like they
don't of the outside of Kevin Durant
there's not a lot of number-one picks on
that roster
Steph Curry was pick seven he got passed
over by a number of teams but this
Rockies team came from a long ways away
and then maybe that's one reason I think
there's a lot of reasons but for a team
that's rarely totally new together there
is a collective purpose that these guys
have shown to the place there's been
really impress
and maybe it's that they've all had to
fight and maybe it's also that they're
just really good
the night that Dwane Casey one coach of
the year here in Los Angeles at the NBA
Awards making the decision that you
Jairam made to fire him look even worse
if I had come up to you that night Bruce
Arthur and said hey guess what the NBA
Finals game one's gonna start in Toronto
next year against the Warriors what
would you said well I didn't have Kawhi
Leonard yet did I would oh great
but Kawhi changes everything and that's
like Nick nurse has been really good as
a coach he's had to adjust the playoffs
was going on I think he's really gotten
comfortable as well the defense he
unleashes on team so the Adrian Griffin
is your number one defensive assistant
there is ferocious it's the number one
reason I think this series could go
really long the Raptors don't have a
chance
but the Kawhi has changed everything
about this team because the poise they
share was kawaiiboys right the the
crunch time
what kind of moxie they've shown has
been kawaii they really do follow him
and he is he is he is even better than I
thought he was going to be and I was
telling people here when they traded for
quite Leonard that you won't believe how
good this guy is but he kind of hit it
all seasons like he was just he really
did practice for the 60 games he played
and it turns out he had levels to get to
and I still think there's another level
for Kawhi to get to in his finals I'm
really interested to see what it is
looking at me - is there a sense of
dread as well that this is a one one and
done one shot only one one finals only
opportunity with Kawhi I think I think
it's in the back of people's minds but
the joy and the experience has been so
rich that people are kind of putting it
off right like they're not thinking
about the future because he's already
authored so many moments that are among
the best in Raptors history the shot he
hits in Game four in Philadelphia he
shot in Game seven against Philadelphia
the work he did in a Milwaukee series
like this guy is unbelievable and it is
true like nobody knows nobody even knows
let's say this team goes and wins a
championship upsets Golden State nobody
knows that that will ensure that Kawhi
would resign in Toronto he's a different
cat and at the end of this
we're gonna find out what Kauai really
wants right like part of it is gonna be
basketball abilities camera basketball
and health which he's been healthy here
but it's possible he wants to live in
Southern California and if that's the
case he'll cosign with the Clippers I
would expect
nobody knows yet so the Raptor to me the
Raptors have between four and seven
games of Kawhi Leonard left and it is a
special thing and this team has a chance
to against a dynasty team like an
awesome Warriors team and I'm not
thinking making up shots and I don't
know if they're gonna figure out the
Warriors offense quickly enough but I
think they're gonna play and I think
Kauai is really gonna play and if he
leaves it's interesting I think it might
be the first time there's a lot of guys
who've left this town I don't know if
you could really be mad at him because
he's given so much on this run
so two Raptors fans to the basketball in
the country she wants to go live at home
and that's fine he goes with lives at
home
if he stays then everything's possible I
mean well he's here almost everything's
possible anyway a few more minutes left
with Toronto Star's Bruce Arthur here on
the Rich Eisen show has has has he dined
or wined in any of the Kauai n-- and
dine decal dressed on sand
establishments has he actually take
advantage of the free meals that he's
being offered by the the folks there in
Toronto best you can tell I have no I
have no evidence that Kawhi Leonard
leaves his house very much right like
there's very there's very little about
Kawhi Leonard out on social media out
about town nice I mean he's got a new
child and like there are people that
have asked who I Leonard a various
points through the season where do you
live and he's like I'm not sure he's got
a car service takes it's not good for
he's not I think he understands that the
city is really excited but I don't think
he spent a lot of time enjoying the city
itself is my impression but the thing
with Kawhi is he keeps everything so
low-key and so private that there's all
kinds of stuff going on but I'm sure
none of us know about maybe he's been
out to more restaurants than we know or
maybe he's just ordering them all into
the house so what would this mean Bruce
I mean it's been since the 66-67 season
for the Leafs to bring home the cup and
it's been 20
some odd years though 26 years since the
cito Gaston Wham Co Blue Jays brought
the World Series trophy to Toronto what
would this mean if it actually happens
it's kind of crazy to say this this
would be the first major championship in
Toronto sports and I'm not including
Major League Soccer or the CFL in the
Internet era right like is 93 Joe Carter
hits the home run
no one's tweeting about that that's
right like that song on YouTube now but
only after fact right this this has the
potential I mean for basketball in
Canada it takes it up a hundred notches
right like it just it just pushes it
across the country and it gives everyone
a memory right a shared memory it
already kind of has but if you get a
championship different thing entirely I
don't know if it matters for Kauai and
maybe it does maybe he can't remember
you as a championship he can't walk away
that would be enormous for the franchise
that has huge Domino effects and for the
city this city seems some really awful
things man it's like it's been a really
tough run the Leafs haven't been in a
Stanley Cup final since they had more
than six teams like they had six teams
in the NHL in 1967 as soon as they
expanded the Leafs never got there again
so this this is a town that has been
relentlessly incompetent when it comes
to sports and the Jays had a brief
window police are in a bit of a
beginning as of a window now does the
Raptors win a title the city's were
waiting for something like this for a
long time and I think it'll just explode
what about the entire country though
Bruce I mean are there are there still
people like I guess in Montreal or
rooting against them rudabeh Warriors
fans just out of spite I mean we're I'm
always I'm always interested in sports
Speight is there any still oh there is
that dynamic in this country you're
raised to not like Toronto because it's
it thinks it's so great if you live in
the rest of Canada absolutely it's an
arrogant town its referred to itself as
the center of the universe but I think
what's happening with the J like it
happened with the Jays when they want a
title and I think it's happening with
the rapper's now is at some point some
teams can cross over into the
bloodstream and and and become something
that's kind of pan-canadian beyond just
Ronald I think anecdotally that seems to
be happening for the Raptors and you see
it in TV ratings they went over three
million for Game six against Milwaukee
to put that in perspective you guys in
America about 10 people for everyone
that we have so that's like a 30 million
person audience right enough that's
something they've never done before and
people are starting to watch people are
starting to get this basketball came
from a long ways back in this country
like when they when we got NBA teams
people had to explain the rules for five
years and and where we are now is the
sport that anyone can play that's being
played more across country than ever was
we have more NBA players in this country
than we've ever had it's growing it's a
we're now becoming a basketball
country's Hollywood describe it and this
would be a big step in pushing it up a
notch or two
who knows what last one for you Bruce
which player from the early days of the
Raptors would you be thinking of if the
Raptors pull this off which which person
would you be thinking of from the early
days or throughout that be you know what
this this would have been neat if said
player was part of this team etc oh
that's really that's a really
interesting question because I mean the
history is so undistinguished right like
to me there's people who have been a
part of the organization weren't a part
of it anymore who I wish we're still
here unlike Jim O Bloomberg was a PR guy
for 20 years best PR guy in the league
and he left last year he went to the NBA
and I mean he missed out on this in
terms of players a guy like Jose called
her and someone who still beloved in
this town a guy that people loved I wish
I wish Chris Bosh was here doing TV
during the finals I wish he could have
stayed and had a better career here I
mean he went to Miami and it was great
and he had a tragic end to his career in
terms of blood clots
I wish they could have done something
better for a player like that a lot of
people are gonna think about Vince and
Vince because Vince is still the most
powerful emotional touchstone in the
history of this franchise in terms of
people who love him and hate him still
to this day I wonder if this is enough
to eclipse Vince to be something bigger
than than something we lost as a kind of
city as a fanbase as for the franchise I
think it could be even if Kauai walks
because they will have created something
win or lose in this final they've
created something that people will
remember forever and that's if you're a
sports fan
that's all you can really ask for from
your French
great stuff Bruce putting voice to the
what you put out there in print it's
it's awesome and I'll I hope we get to
speak throughout the finals rich on a
huge fan it was my pleasure to be on the
show thanks brother
that's Bruce Arthur at Bruce underscore
Arthur on Twitter for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app